Well, thank you all so much
for being here today,
because I am super excited to tell you
that we are about to explore
space in a big way.
And the future of space exploration
is like nothing we’ve ever seen before,
and the future is one
we can hardly even imagine.
Well, why is that?
We’ve been exploring space
since the 1950s,
so what’s different now?
Well, for the first time ever,
we are going to be using
supersized spacecraft
for our journey into the solar system.
This is the Starship vehicle
that’s being developed
by the company SpaceX.
This vehicle will be able
to launch more mass --
or payload --
have more power
and be able to launch over
and over and over again,
more than any spacecraft
ever designed or built, ever.
So the Starship
and its Super Heavy booster
are a fully reusable
transportation system.
So that means that you don’t
have to build a new vehicle
every time you want to fly.
And so what that does
is that reduces the cost of each flight
and it lets you have more flights.
Now historically, rockets have been
used once, and then that’s it.
But if you think about it,
would you ever build an airplane,
fly it once
and then throw it away?
Like, no, that’s ridiculous,
because the cost of each flight
would be way too high,
and you wouldn’t have
very many flights, right?
So let’s put this
in perspective a little bit.
So think about the last rover
that we just sent to Mars.
It is an amazing mission;
it’s still on Mars collecting great data.
So the launch cost for that mission
was 243 million dollars.
So that works out to be
about 100,000 dollars per pound
to launch that rover to Mars.
And that’s where we are today.
So SpaceX is aiming to have
a launch cost for Starship
on the order of a couple million dollars.
And so that means that you could
launch that same Mars rover
for about 900 dollars per pound.
So that’s 100,000 dollars
versus 900 dollars.
That’s a huge difference.
And actually, it's probably
cheaper than that
because you could fit like 100
of those Mars rovers inside one Starship
because it’s just that big.
It’s really incredible.
And it’s not just SpaceX.
There are multiple commercial companies
building new rockets now
of all different sizes,
for all different purposes.
And this is great because this is really
helping to open up space to more people.
So here’s an image
of some of the current rockets
compared to NASA’s mighty Saturn V rocket.
So the Saturn V is the rocket
that launched astronauts to the Moon
in the ’60s and ’70s.
The last Saturn V launched in 1973.
And full disclosure,
I was not even born yet,
so I think this is incredibly unfair
because there has never been
a rocket more powerful since.
So I just have to emphasize
that the changes
we’re talking about today,
these are not incremental, small advances
in rocketry and spacecraft.
These are truly
transformational technologies
that are giving us
completely new capabilities
and changing the paradigm
for space exploration.
And what’s really going to happen
is we’re going to move
from where we are today,
which is usually, you know,
more specialized, one-off,
boutique-style missions
into more mass-produced,
large-scale operations in space.
And the reason is because
we are being largely freed
of these traditional, very severe
mass and cost restraints
that we’ve been working under
in the aerospace industry for decades.
Now there is one vehicle
that’s really forced us
to change the conversation
regarding space exploration
and space architectures,
and that is the Starship.
That entire system is designed
to be even more powerful
than the Saturn V.
And the Starship vehicle itself
will be able to launch
over 100 metric tons of payload
to Earth orbit,
to the surface of the Moon,
to the surface of Mars
and even beyond.
Like, 100 metric tons of payload.
Like, that’s crazy.
That is a crazy number
that we would never
have been discussing a while ago
because in spaceflight,
we are always trying
to reduce mass, right?
Miniaturize your components,
have your instruments
be as lightweight as possible
because of the mass and cost constraints.
And so now we actually have
the opposite problem
where we have to figure out, like --
how are we going to fill
100 metric tons of payload?
Like, seriously, like,
what are we going to fly?
So this is a great place to be,
and it’s a great problem to have.
How can you actually fly such a ridiculous
amount of payload into the solar system?
Well, Starship will conveniently
refill its propellant tanks in space
with methane and oxygen.
So the way that this works
is you launch your first Starship, right?
You’ve got your payload you want to send
wherever into the solar system.
You launch that into orbit.
Then you launch another Starship,
and we’ll just call it a tanker because
it’s basically just another Starship,
but it’s full of propellant.
And then those two vehicles meet
and they dock in Earth orbit.
And the tanker refills
the propellant tanks of your starship.
So essentially what you’re doing
is you’re refilling your gas tanks
before you go out on a big, long trip.
And that’s how you can send
so much payload capacity
out into the solar system.
Now this is so important
because Earth is such
a large gravity well.
It just takes so much energy,
and hence, so much fuel,
just to launch off
the surface of the Earth.
So by refilling the tanks in space,
we’re essentially resetting
the rocket equation in orbit,
and then we can send these payloads
out to wherever they need to go.
So this is fantastic.
Like, we have this new capability
and this is how it works,
but now I’d like to go
to the really exciting part:
What are we going
to do with this capability?
So consider this.
Scientists, myself included,
have long been interested
in the possibility of life on Europa.
Europa has a subsurface --
salty, liquid-water ocean --
and we wonder if life
might be able to exist there.
So given our current
exploration strategies --
there is a mission in development
right now to study Europa,
it’ll actually orbit Jupiter
and it’ll do flybys of Europa
and remotely measure
the Moon and its ocean.
But how about this?
So I envision a future
where to study Europa’s ocean,
we send submarines
down into the ocean itself.
And we study the ocean
from within the ocean,
and we directly search for signs of life.
And while we’re at it,
we should also send
submersibles to Enceladus.
Enceladus is a moon of Saturn.
It’s amazing.
It also has a subsurface --
salty, liquid-water ocean --
because we see
literally geysers of water ice
coming out of its south polar region.
And it’s not just Europa and Enceladus.
The outer solar system
is full of ocean worlds.
And if we have learned one thing
about studying life on Earth --
which, by the way, also an ocean world --
it’s that all life requires
liquid water to survive.
So we wonder:
Could there be life
in these other oceans as well?
There’s other possibilities, too.
Let’s consider astronomy and astrophysics.
This is a beautiful image
from the Hubble Space Telescope
in the constellation of Orion.
It is a nebula:
a star-forming region
where new stars are being born.
And in order to understand
these processes in the universe,
we need large telescopes in space
to send us back this type of data.
Now you could fit a telescope three times
the diameter of Hubble in a Starship.
You could actually fit several of those
very large telescopes in a Starship.
And that’s important
because telescopes --
size matters, right?
The telescope is like
a light-collecting bucket,
and you want to collect
as many photons as you possibly can
to see objects that are faint
and to see objects that are far away.
Because the telescope --
a telescope is a time machine.
The further away an object is,
the older it is,
because it takes a finite amount of time
for that light to travel
from that object to your eyeball, right?
That's why it's called the speed of light.
So with these larger telescopes,
we can address these science questions,
like searching for exoplanets,
planets around other stars
and understanding the formation of stars
and planetary systems ...
and looking back to the cosmic dawn --
the literal beginning of time --
and fundamentally understanding
our own place in the universe.
But it's not just the size
of the telescopes.
We can also reduce the cost.
So the James Webb Space Telescope --
JWST --
fantastic instrument,
amazing.
The telescope is relatively large,
so it didn't fit on any existing
launch vehicles.
So it had to be folded up,
like a piece of origami,
to fit on the rocket.
So if we have larger vehicles
that can launch larger telescopes,
we can just launch them
already fully assembled, right?
No deployment in space necessary.
So the science that can
be enabled is amazing,
but it's about more than the science.
It’s also about the exploration.
Because for the first time
in the history of our entire planet --
and that’s about a little over
four and a half billion years
for anybody that’s keeping track --
we are on the cusp of having both
the scientific and technical capability
to send humans to build a future
off of our home planet.
And here's how we're going
to do it on Mars.
So first we need to send
uncrewed starships to Mars.
I mean, we have to prove
that we can safely land those vehicles
before we can send humans on them.
But we will use that amazing
payload capacity of the Starships
to send elements that we need
in order to enable a sustained
human presence on Mars.
And we’re going to start
with what we call ISRU:
In-Situ Resource Utilization.
That basically means living off the land.
Because if we want to have
a self-sustaining presence on Mars,
we cannot be Earth-reliant, right?
We cannot ferry everything we need
from Earth to Mars all the time.
You know, living off of local resources --
it’s been critical to human survival
since the beginning of our entire species.
Our ancestors for millennia have been
learning how to use local resources
to do things like, you know, build tools
and grow food
and generate energy.
So, I mean, we’re lucky.
We live on a pretty cushy
planet right now.
That’s why we’re all here today:
we have everything that we need.
But Mars is different.
And Mars is unforgiving.
And if you run out of food
or fuel
or oxygen,
you’re done.
So we have to be very smart
about how we do ISRU on Mars.
And the way we’re going to start
is by using water ice as a resource.
We know Mars has lots of water ice.
There’s ground ice,
there’s rock-covered glaciers,
there’s ice for us to use.
Now, traditionally, when people talk
about sending humans to Mars,
we talk about sending like a few people
and maybe a little rover
so they can drive around
and explore a little bit.
But Starship is so transformational
that now we can talk about sending
the heavy-duty construction machinery
to build the infrastructure that we need
for a large-scale presence on Mars.
So I’m talking like dump trucks
and backhoes and large drill rigs --
all the things we’re going to need
for ISRU and beyond.
(Laughter)
And another thing that we need to do
before the humans arrive
is serach for Indigenous Martian life.
So this is a top-priority
science question.
Is there life on Mars?
But we also have to do due diligence
to make sure that
that landing site is safe
for the humans to come and live and work.
So once we get all that
robotic precursor work done,
then the humans can arrive.
And this is when we start
building up a base
and moving towards a civilization on Mars.
Now just imagine that for a moment, right?
At this point, there will
actually be Martians,
except they will be people
like you and me.
And it’s about more than just Mars,
because as we develop this capability
to send humans into the solar system,
we can truly begin
to address questions such as:
Are we alone in the universe,
and can humans thrive off-planet?
So the opportunities that are afforded us
by these supersized spacecraft
are truly unprecedented,
and they’re like nothing
that we’ve ever had before.
And they’re completely changing
the paradigm for space exploration.
It has taken the entire
history of our planet
to reach this point right now.
So I think it’s an amazing
time to be alive,
because what we do next will forever
change the course of human history.
So now is the time to seize
the opportunity
and expand humanity
throughout the cosmos.
Thank you.
(Applause)